former Republican strategist and a
former guest on our show Tim Miller
recently confronted Trump propaganda
Stephen Bannon and it's really really
good wait to the House of
Representatives next year when we have a
real j6 committee and we're going to
adjudicate oh no we're going to
adjudicate all of three November we
can't we're not going to believe that
100 youth uh
100 and she still thinks it was and
she's still talking about 100 people
storms or Capital over this dude these
are these are lines that was not by
Trump
by the way if you weren't lying about it
that wouldn't happen and one of the
interesting things about Bannon is he
really seems completely unfazed at being
called out being confronted and there's
two reasons why that could be one is he
genuinely is convinced that he's right
about everything and the second is he
just really doesn't care how he looks
he's happy just repeating his same old
tropes really wild stuff to see and
really nice job by Tim Miller